I'll be talking about kind of some of
the work that uh we've been working on
at a telescope um and uh and yeah uh so
I'm a data scientist at uh telescope and
kind of a little bit of a background
about what telescope does is we actually
uh are kind of a data security platform
uh that allows uh our customers to kind
of inventory and take take kind of a
global view of where any of their
sensitive data or any of their secrets
are are located within their kind of
data data stores whether this is a
structure data store a unstructured data
store maybe it's chats in slack or or
other kind of conversational data this
is kind of where uh we service our
customers and so
um that's kind of where I'm currently at
formerly I was a machine learning
engineer at a company called Forge uh
recently acquired by a company called
fiscal node and basically doing a lot of
NLP work there working with knowledge
graphs uh trying to kind of create
entity intelligence from open source
intelligence uh getting news information
uh also as everyone probably knows it's
uh opening day today baseball is back so
uh they thank God we made it uh and uh
in my free time I'm a hobby Potter so I
just wanted to throw a couple fun things
in there
um yeah so let me kind of describe the
problem in a in a couple kind of words
here uh once we've kind of gone through
the process of developing a model which
obviously uh there are many steps to it
uh but we want to kind of figure out uh
we want to make sure that our model is
doing what we are expecting it to do we
want to make sure that we're predicting
what we we thought we were predicting
based on our training uh Loops based on
kind of our our kind of our development
cycle we want to kind of uh keep track
of that and and kind of prevent our uh
are kind of a predictions to kind of
drift away from what we expect uh and so
why is this a problem for us at
telescope uh there are many kind of ways
to to kind of solve this problem uh at a
traditional company but we're kind of
given the benefit of uh or not the
benefit but the responsibility of
classifying over customers sensitive
data and while while we would love to be
able to go in and kind of spot check
things we really don't have a way of
going into their actual data and
checking to make sure that our
classifications were correct making sure
that our actual
um
predictions were leading to the correct
kind of uh decision making after that um
data drift are kind of our training data
can only be so representative of what
our customers actually have and so we
want to kind of make sure that our
actual uh training data uh is it's
closely represented to the production
environment data but we'll never
actually have that certainty uh we won't
always we won't know exactly that our
data fully matches what our customers
data looks like
uh same thing it's possible that we kind
of have blind spots in the training
process and so this is just another kind
of uh additional kind of check in the in
the cycle to make sure that we are
properly kind of uh preparing ourselves
for conversations with customers and
making sure that they feel confident
that our uh kind of predictions are
gonna are gonna help them in their
decision making process uh another
reason this is a problem is basically
we all love like the new shiny thing so
once you've got the model ready and you
think that it's great you kind of set it
and forget it and so operationalizing
this kind of uh quality control like
Loop is is pretty critical in kind of
making sure that uh your models are
actually doing what you expect them to
do
uh and and finally
similar to kind of this kind of Shifting
desire to work on something new it's
also possible that the business
priorities shift and while this is seen
as a very critical part of your business
you might not actually be able to spend
the time to continue this maintenance
down the line so kind of setting that up
from the beginning is pretty critical
so the the usual approaches which I said
were kind of uh are pretty critical
regardless of kind of having their
quality training data that's
representative uh of uh what the
customer state is going to look like
making sure you make the kind of uh the
right architecture changes we don't want
to be working with a
extremely deep model if we need some
extremely low latency we want something
that actually fits the customer's needs
we don't want an analyst waiting five
minutes for something that they need to
decide on in a few seconds so kind of uh
making sure that the uh architecture is
correct
um like I said we don't have the ability
to spot check the results but this is a
very valid kind of way of making sure
that your your model is doing what you
expected to do
um if if you have the ability to kind of
look at that kind of a customer data uh
and you're able to exploit that
um
the kind of the critical thing that we
uh at telescope also get to take
advantage of is the actual kind of uh
customer feedback uh whether that's uh a
kind of a a thumbs up if uh if something
looks good or kind of some negative
feedback or more of like a change in the
taxonomy needs to be made or something
like this kind of customer feedback is
is pretty critical
um to uh um
to continue to improve your model uh and
and yeah so once uh uh um you've done
all that the last thing you can do is
hope for the best
and just kind of kind of uh expect uh
the best but kind of prepare for the
worst and so
at telescope we want what we want to
really do is kind of minimize that that
Last Detail there we don't want to hope
for the best we want to kind of prepare
ourselves like I said with additional
approaches
um so our kind of approach uh and this
kind of is a combination of uh using
work that I've done in the past with uh
um with Forge where we relied heavily on
open source intelligence uh and and at
telescope where I'm building where we're
building the model uh to actually
identify this kind of a pii uh it's
typically around uh just named entities
or or other types of um
uh sensitive information
um
we basically go down the approach of
looking for uh open source kind of data
apis and so there are plenty of uh
closed Source uh data that you can kind
of uh buy but we went on the approach of
trying to kind of surface a larger uh um
uh variety of data and so we we went and
found kind of a list of apis that were
open source and kind of met our
um our requirements when it comes to
copyright use and uh there's plenty of
these lists on GitHub uh and then maybe
also even like sites that we frequently
use that provide kind of this data as
kind of a an API and making sure you're
just kind of
um resembling the data that might exist
in your production environment uh for us
that could look like something like
conversation data could also look at
like tabular data uh information that
our customers might have about vendors
or employees and so basically uh in this
particular example we focused on
conversation data but
um but it it just needs to resemble in
theory what your production data is
going to look like uh like I said
determine those copyright requirements
you don't want to get a nice lawsuit
later because you're using uh the wrong
wrong type of data uh and then be a good
internet user don't kind of uh
overwhelm a service that you really like
and uh lose that uh ability so we we
rely on kaggle for some of this stuff
but there's obviously tons of other
um open source kind of tools that are
open source data sets that that you can
kind of uh integrate into into this kind
of a feedback loop here
um now and more kind of describing the
actual architecture of what we did um
the data is the first part now we need a
kind of a way of Distributing this task
over time uh at telescope we kind of do
this in our development environment and
it's possible that our development
environment is always shifting maybe it
goes down because we're running
migrations or updating and so uh we kind
of want to distribute these tasks and
have kind of this kind of uh fail
protection and so we kind of relied
heavily on the salary test queue so
anyone here used celery before it's a
pretty uh it's pretty commonly used uh
library and basically just uh a ton of
great kind of features for this
particular work creating the cron jobs I
think allows you to have a very regular
kind of um
uh either data polling or classification
which I'll describe in the next uh slide
um but yeah I can uh also it also has
tons of connectors to existing queue
systems and then additionally
um it allows you to purchase that data
to a database so that you can kind of
continue the analysis Beyond just
running this kind of end-to-end test
basically
um so with the with celery we basically
go and we fetch the data from the apis
that we've uh pre kind of uh selected
that fit our our model
um it it might also be useful for you to
just select random data too because you
want to see what your model might do
with random data because sometimes that
kind of testing is is important to see
these edge cases but for us we kind of
focused on like the the data that
resembles our
um our production environment
um
and then we kind of uh like I said using
the the kind of the configuration you
can control the volume of data that
that's getting pulled in the amount of
data that's uh getting pushed onto onto
these cues from those cues you can then
run the classifications through your
entire system so we provide our
customers basically with a API that
allows you to scan uh or scrub
um the scan or the classify endpoint
basically tells you what entities
existed in that context uh and then the
scrub will redact it so that if there is
any pii or any Phi it is eliminated from
the underlying text
um and then uh so we'll run those
classifications and then like I said
it'll persist that in the database so
we'll have kind of like a running
history of maybe the last month or the
last two months of of these
classifications which is pretty
essential for for some of these kind of
um
uh later tasks like regression testing
or just performance and uh reporting
like maybe uh maybe the customer wants
to know exactly how we perform on on a
particular uh government passport or
like a particular like a um pii uh
element
um so just a quick kind of like graph
here of like what I've described and so
you can kind of see we start with like
the data you go to the uh um the task
queue once we've pulled the data off of
the uh result uh then we run through the
classification model uh in our case uh
it could be whatever model you you have
within your pipeline uh put the result
back on the task queue and then uh you
persist those results on the database so
at this point we have kind of this uh
this data set that is is great but it
doesn't actually have any kind of
validation or any information about how
well you're doing or how well your uh
performance is doing so uh once we have
like uh all this data uh we can actually
go through and kind of go through a very
similar Loop that we would do if we were
doing a training basically so uh one of
the kind of the annotation shops that
we've used a telescope is scale AI but
we also do some internal kind of review
um and so we basically uh exploit the
kind of the the uh the configuration
where it allows you to kind of pick how
many
um annotators you want what kind of
inter annotator agreement you want if
there's any kind of uh
um review beyond that you need uh and
then you can kind of uh um send those
over the
um over their API additionally we've
used an open source tool called docano
which I really really recommend if
you've ever if you ever need to do any
kind of they they do a ton of different
types of annotation but uh we use it for
natural language obviously but it could
also be something like uh uh image
segmentation and additional tools it's
open source and you can host it yourself
and it it's yeah it's uh it's great I
recommend it
um but yeah so we basically go uh and
and
we go on a weekly kind of basis we pull
off some results subset of the results
that we had generated over the past week
uh we send over those to scale uh
obviously if if you want to do that
internal annotation uh you can do that
yourself as well and send it to docato
they expose an API and then those
results get persisted in a additional
database
um
so with these kind of results uh we can
kind of uh compute a handful of
different metrics which are important
for stakeholders important to kind of uh
to share with customers uh during that
kind of uh that acquisition process when
they're trying to kind of decide between
vendors
um we can also give them a much more
fine-grained kind of uh um description
of our results uh and then we can do
this kind of regression testing where if
we have a a new model that we're working
on deploying uh we want to make sure
that the changes are positive changes we
want to make sure that we're not kind of
uh changing the whole system uh and and
kind of breaking some of the previous uh
classifications so basically uh
comparison of previous models
um and then uh the the kind of the the
the kicker here is that we also get this
additional training data for future kind
of model improvements maybe down the
line we want to move to a smaller kind
of a model that doesn't rely as much on
the uh the pre-trained model or
something uh it's possible that uh we
have a lower compute envelope
um or a smaller compute envelope that we
need to fit and so in those situations
we might need a larger training set to
kind of get a the simple a similar
amount of results and so having this
additional training data is kind of
essential uh for us
um so just kind of an overview here uh
some of the kind of the the processes
that we have Downstream are kind of
generating the
um uh these kind of F1 recall split uh
um
graphs and basically creating a
dashboard around it
um so we'll create this dashboard so we
can have kind of a pretty regularly
updated
um idea of how our performance is uh for
our customers uh and then uh we use
these findings to kind of determine if
we're gonna need to get additional data
from uh um
from different sources uh or if we're
doing pretty good uh
um according to our kind of our external
kind of test set here
um so I'll wrap up with some final
thoughts here
um as you kind of expect the usual
approaches are still extremely important
um even this augmented data set is not
going to be always 100 consistent with
uh the data that your customer has so
you still have to kind of rely on these
usual approaches which in our case like
I said customer feedback you really need
to kind of take advantage of of an
Engaged customer if they're giving you
signal in a certain way it's pretty
critical that you um
that you listen to them there
um the initial training set and The
annotation guide I mean as with any kind
of a
supervised task that is a pretty kind of
a foundational part uh the visibility
here is key um if if our customers want
to know if if our stakeholders
internally want to know uh what our
performance looks like uh it's uh um it
needs to be an easy task for them to go
like into a grafana dashboard or
something and quickly pull that off
um and yeah and we've definitely had
some initial success uh at a telescope
kind of
having to roll back regressions before
they make it to the customers is always
nicer than having to do it after and so
making sure we catch those kind of uh
those really uh weird edge cases uh
beforehand uh has been really helpful
um yeah that's it uh thanks for
listening
[Music]